You guys can hear it, right?
Yeah.
Yes.
So people were like, what are you doing?
It's the music!
It's the background music!
You hear it?
It's kind of like
Friday the 13th.
The music's a little quiet.
Oh, it's so loud in my ear.
It's so loud for me.
It is not quiet.
We'll put it like here.
It should be better, right?
That's loud, I don't know what they mean.
Ma'am, I joined your membership, but I have a request.
Could you use your OL skills to really sell your membership
to me?
Sales pitch.
When you hear sales pitch, what do you think?
You might be intimidated.
You might think, I don't want to be sailed to.
you know I'm tone deaf so pitch is not my forte I don't even
like using the word forte because I'm not musically inclined
but I would say that that my pitch is pitch perfect and if
you want more quality content such as that you should join
my memberships.
The Membou ships.
Sold.
Thank you.
Wait, now I'm low and the game is loud?
Okay, I'm gonna turn it back down then.
Oh, oh.
I think I have to do it manually.
Wait.
Okay.
Thank you guys for the gift.
Thank you.
I'll take your entire stock.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Wait, it lit up for like two seconds.
Uh.
Oh.
They turned into fake buttons.
What happened?
What even happened?
Oh.
see see it lit up maybe I
don't know I have no idea anyway hello everybody welcome to
that's not my neighbor oh it's a game kind of like hold on
it's a game kind of like a paper please where you If you
don't know that game, like you have people coming and you
have to see what is the, what's the, they are not who they
say they are.
It might be that their nose is wrong or they're, they're,
they might have multiple eyeballs.
Who knows?
Anything is possible.
No, that is not a solid neighbor.
Exactly.
Glory to Ars Tosca.
Yes, but today we are, I don't know where we are.
wait it's February 1955 we're in old-timey mmm dear mint you
are getting one guide love Cheggie I can't tell anymore I
can't tell anymore will Georgie be there it's hard to say
Georgie Georgie is the best guy but mmm we might have
imposter georgie it's kind of like yeah like like some of
these guys are like trying trying to dress up as your
neighbor but they're not real they're like spooky monsters
and stuff so it's kind of fun so let's uh let's just play it
i i've never played this before so oh see the doppelgangers
you let in don't kill you immediately but at the end of the
run okay get a score rank at the end of the, I can't, I
mean, they can't choose anything else, so.
Doppelgangers is what they're called.
Possibility to find and complete the Chester's quiz.
I have no idea what that is.
I've never played this before.
Oh.
But we're gonna check it out.
The following short film is a production of DDD with
educational finds.
Finds.
Hello, if you're watching Watching this film, it's because
you're the new doorman in your building!
Your job is to determine whether the person who wants to
enter the building is a doppelganger.
As everyone knows, doppelgangers have the ability to
transform into another person and impersonate them.
But some are not too good at it, and could generate
imperfections.
You have to pay close attention to the appearance of your
neighbors.
really judgmental.
Got it.
Also, remember to fill out the checklist for each neighbor.
You can't miss any detail because it could mean death for
you and your neighbors.
Ah!
This is the structure of your office.
Now we are going to explain how it works.
This is so cute.
Here is the security window.
Don't forget to observe very well each individual who
approaches.
okay my big eyes on the right you have the folders with all
the data of each neighbor according to the respective floor
to fill out the checklist take each one of the lists in
front of you what receive documents from this hatch okay I
should probably be paying attention right B, B, B.
If you determine that the individual isn't a doppelganger,
then allow them into the building with these buttons.
The apostrophe.
Otherwise, if you determine that it is in fact a
doppelganger, press the emergency button and call 3-3-1-2.
Okay.
To communicate with the DDD or any apartment in your
building, use the telephone in front of you.
I've never seen a telephone before.
Oh, hot dog.
Yippee!
Yee-haw!
We're in the future!
Your job is really important, so make sure you do it right!
What was the number?
Uh-oh.
Finally, we congratulate the doorman of the month, Henry!
It wasn't that he did an excellent job, but he was the only
doorman in the area who didn't get killed by doppelgangers.
3-3-1-2?
Be like Henry.
But better!
Oh, he looks so...
Like, okay.
Every time...
Oh!
Welcome and congratulations on your new job.
Oh, that's right here.
It's 3-3-1-2.
As you can see in the introductory film, your job is to
verify the entry of the neighbors of your building.
Each day there will be a list of individuals who will
request entry to the building.
It is possible that there are individuals who request entry
and aren't.
on the list in which case you will mark on the checklist
that they are not on the list and proceed to question the
individual also you must verify that the ID and the entry
requests are correct and have the respective DDD logo don't
forget to also check the expiration date on the IDs remember
it's February 1955 yeah yeah I got it I wish you good luck
see ya okay that was a lot of That was a lot of info dub at
the very beginning.
Oh, good afternoon.
This guy looks like a real Muppet.
He looks like a Muppet on the run.
Oh my gosh.
Mucho texto.
Roman Stiltsky.
48392.4059684.
Uh-huh.
With the DDD.
There's an idol I like that has a song.
called DDD so now I can't get it out of my head entry
request Roman Stilnski apartment F0101 reason I'm a resident
of the building I've come from my job as a public accountant
accountant why do you have the scar if you're just an
accountant huh hmm hmm wait so I have to see this list well
why aren't you on the oh wait okay checklist checklist ID
seems good also he's wearing a hat oh here Roman Stiltsky
accountant appearance big nose scar on right chin long face
one eyebrow where's a hat where's a hat where's a hat
where's a hat where's a hat wait one eyebrow ID appearance
is it on today's no question i'm not on today's list because
i had to leave due to an emergency at work
is that a valid response or
entry request wait what's the end is this entry oh yes
i'm not on today oh that's sus oh call the apartment you're
right you're right right Ah!
Uh, go back, go back.
Uh, uh, one, one, five, two.
One, one, five, two.
Yes?
Hello!
Lois, still speaking?
My husband is not at home.
Okay.
so he's he actually did go is he back maybe i don't know is
it him it could not be him it could be an imposter maybe and
his card was 19 they wouldn't give me a fake guy on the
first run right mochie mochie
he seems okay
okay i hope we don't die Oh.
Hello, good day.
Hello, Miss.
Rafftelen Kapachinin.
What?
These old-timey names.
Oh, she's on the list.
She's on the list.
Wait.
Tell me you, Afton.
Like a Mr. Williams.
William Afton Of Five Nights at Freddy's fame No way
Also isn't Mia Stone The name of an actress Okay Rafftillion
That sounds like reptilian I'm just saying Wait what floor
are you on 62 um oh three oh four i'm a resident of this
building my apartment is on the is the o4 on the third floor
that's oh yeah raftilian reptilian says she is a housewife
long face big note this is so judgmental who are we to say
that this is a big nose right
straight hair she looks the same right she wears a headband
yeah Freddy oh ID number let's check if it's It's the same,
five, six, eight, five, five, four, five, nine, six, three,
two, nine.
It's the same.
I think we're good.
She has a reason to go out.
She has a little thing, so I think we're good.
All right, ma'am.
Excellent.
The door, please.
You seem a little eager, reptilian.
What if I just let you mingle out there, huh?
Blood on the dress.
I think that's a pattern.
I think that's a floral pattern.
Wait, her shirt's different?
Oh, we can't see her shirt.
I think that's a floral pattern.
I don't think that's blood, you guys.
I can see the flower details on it.
Okay, let's let her in.
I don't like that sound.
It's so loud.
okay hope we don't die oh hello Lois Stiltsky God damn mr.
Stiltsky oh you wait you were home oh oh wait she was that's
that's not the tea that's not her she was home remember we
already talked to her God damn.
I mean, is this?
Is, is, is, is, is this part fake too?
Mr. Stelnski's.
He's a lucky man.
Let's, let's do the checklist.
ID, they might be the same.
Nice.
to just check everything you know get our ducks in an order
see what parts are fake you know 8 9 4 5 6 9 7 2 3 6 5 1
okay so this is oh no no oh wait yes my teeth ah they are
for better eating my dear what does that mean I already
answered your question oh she's getting a little spicy with
me eating what yeah eating what ma'am big lips molan left
cheek cheek round face short hair she does have a pretty
round face it's the teeth though entry request oh yeah she's
obviously not on the list so oh wait she doesn't have it I'm
not on today's list because I had to leave due to an
emergency I'm gonna call the apartment.
What was it?
1-1-5-2.
I wanna see what they say.
1-5-2.
A likely story.
I like this version of Tono.
Hello!
Roman Stiltsky is speaking.
My wife and I are in the apartment right now.
Wait!
We are not expecting any visitors today.
What if...
What if this is the real wife?
What if that be crazy?
Um, three, three, one, two!
Eject, eject, eject, eject!
The call is coming from inside the house!
What?
Oh, I have to push the button first.
Um, I don't know how loud this is gonna be, so I'm gonna
turn it down just a little bit.
Okay, that wasn't so bad.
Three, three, one.
One, two.
Boil!
Emergency!
You have contacted the tea!
Tea!
A group of agents has been sent to your building.
Thank you.
Please wait for the cleaning protocol to run.
Cleaning protocol?
Oh.
Cleaning protocol completed.
Thank you, sir.
You can continue your duty.
job thank you very much for your service cool good work
Minto thank you good afternoon where is your entry request
my entry request yes your entry I think everything's fine
with my oh I mean where's your ID sorry lift up lift up
there Here we go.
Oh, I'm sorry, yes, I forgot to show my ID.
Oh, you had it this whole time.
Hyper, hyper, thank you for the gift in.
Thank you so much.
Gloria Schmidt.
I think I do remember seeing her on the list.
Yes, zero two, oh yeah, zero two, zero one.
1974 DDD, mm-hmm.
I'm a resident of this building.
I came from my job as a banker.
Wait, what floor are you again?
Two.
She's a banker.
Round face.
Mulan, right cheek.
Short hair, round nose.
Round nose.
Right cheek.
Short hair.
Do we trust bankers?
Let's check her ID number.
6985.
three four one one five oh yes I believe this one is wait
what is this oh oh that's handy hmm oh so I can minimize it
oh that's so handy that's so handy I think she's good if we
get eaten oh wait let me complete the checklist so is
everything in order Yes.
Can you open the door for me?
Yes.
Did you call her house?
Oh, thank you.
5-1-2- Well, she was on the list, but it's probably better,
right?
5-1-2-3.
Yeah, let's call.
Let's call.
Hello.
Whoa, the audio got weird.
Arnold.
My wife is not at home.
Okay, she's here.
Is she back?
She might be.
She could be a doppelganger.
Okay.
Minty can't slack.
I know, I'm sorry.
Oh my gosh, is this Emma Stone?
Good afternoon.
Mia Stone.
1978, DDD.
Who is Emma Stone?
I just know that name, but who is she?
She is an actress?
Oh, okay.
And!
I'm a resident of this building.
My apartment is on the...
Is the O1 on the third floor.
Oh.
I was on the...
what a beautiful couple she's a teacher long hair small
small round nose i'll be the judge of that now if you're
looking for a small round nose i would use mine as an
example but you know what whatever makes her feel good you
know has freckles oval face thin eyebrows
You have no nose.
I have a nose.
Look, you can see it.
See that?
See that nose in all its pointed glory?
Oh, God.
I didn't blow my nose.
I have no tissue.
Okay, we're fine.
Okay.
We're okay.
Sorry.
She's just standing here so patient.
like I hope I don't get eaten.
789-564.
525-115.
525.
Oh.
I was looking at the 4-5-2-5-25-115.
She is on the list.
Excellent.
Can you open the door for Not until I, oh wait, your
husband, he might not be home either.
Oh, whoops, but we'll try, we'll try.
Oh, uh, 1-4-2-5.
1-4-2-5.
I don't think he's going to be home.
They're working, they're a working couple.
Mm-hmm.
So neither of them are home.
Dozo.
I can't say I'm a huge fan of that beeping sound.
It's kind of...
Oh, it's like that.
Oh, it's so loud.
It's so loud.
Uh...
Hello, uh...
Selene?
Uh...
Whoa!
Selene and Eleanor Nwines live together.
Wait, they're twins!
Uh...
Oh, it's Natcha!
Natcha cheese!
Or in this case, Natcha body.
Natcha, Natcha you.
Hi.
Um...
Uh...
Yes?
I'll take that now.
Alright, what about your appearance?
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
Um, you don't have an entry request.
either yeah I mean I'm not your neighbor yeah not your
neighbor
uh hmm I don't know guys what should we do with her feel
kind of bad looks like she's had a hard day you know like
imagine if you like go and get a haircut you don't tell
anyone or like you know someone like jumps you in the back
alley and steals your eyes and your mouth and like you can't
you can't report that right away you can't tell them like
hey sorry i got jumped in the alley and they stole my kidney
and my eyes sell on the black market typical friday like and
then and then i have to call the police on you?
this is such a bad day.
She just wants to go home.
Poor Natcha.
Okay.
Emergency.
Three, three, one, two.
They're coming to get you.
Little doppelganger.
Y'all rain.
in danger.
I'm going to skip this because we...
Cleaning protocol completed.
Thank you.
You can continue your job.
I wish I didn't.
That was frightening.
I hope they cover therapy.
Hi!
Oh, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Are you guys going to say it or am I going to?
Uh...
Oh!
My appearance?
Nose?
My nose?
I was born without a nose.
Oh my gosh.
It's normal for humans.
Yeah.
He was born without a nose.
It's normal.
You heard him.
You heard Mr. Robertsky Peachman.
Peach fuzz.
Oh, he looks so weird.
Wait, I am a resident of the building.
I come home, I come from my job as a shoemaker.
O-1-0-2.
Yes, shoemaker.
2668.
Also, he's not on the list.
Am I not on today's list?
I think there is an error.
I should be on the list.
Look at the list again.
I didn't.
Yep.
Not there, mister.
I already answered your question.
Red flags.
Let's call 2668.
What if he picks up?
Got your nose.
Take the L, bro.
I know.
Hello, Robert's Key Peach.
Wait, isn't that who that guy is supposed to be?
My brother and I are in the apartment right now.
Are you expecting visitors?
We are not expecting any visitors today.
This guy, he looks, without the nose, he looks so much more
suspicious.
Okay, buddy.
I think we're going to have to...
of a good point.
Not everybody has a nose.
Oh, uh, three.
I forget that I have to call.
What if I just sit here for long enough?
Did they get mad or?
Bust him, bust him.
Yeah, we're busting this guy.
Cleaning protocol completed.
How many more do I have to do?
How long is the day?
Milkman!
Hello.
Hmm, hello.
Francis Moses.
1964.
I'm a resident of the building.
I come from my job as a milkman.
No way.
He's really a milkman.
Uh, what was your 302?
Oh, appearance.
I for some reason I read appearance.
Milkman.
Long nose.
Thin chin.
Tired eyes.
Short hair.
Can you take off your hat for me, please?
Oh, where's a hat?
Never mind.
Okay, Francis.
Let me check your...
2, 3, 5, 5, 6, 9, 2, 3, 5, 5, 6, 9, 1, 8, 9, 9, 9, 5, 9, 9,
9, 9, 9, 9, thank you, wait, I can't read it, this game is
all about keeping the Uggos out, don't be mean, no, don't be
mean, um, wait, is he on the list, oh, he is, I think this
guy is a green flag,
Perfect.
The door.
You could say please.
Hold on.
Before I do that, I am going to...
I think it'd be under sound, right?
Oh, but I want you to still hear them and stuff.
I just hate this sound.
Ugh.
It's so loud.
He's tired, Mint.
Yeah, me too.
Oh!
bill.
Wait, is this the elusive Afton?
Dr. W!
Wait, where's the rest of your name?
Oh, Afton.
1971, we know he's on the list.
Oh my god.
Well, um, excuse me.
Where is your entry request?
Here is my entry.
Okay.
Just kidding.
I am a resident of the building.
I come from my job as a
Okay, yes sir, physicist.
301.
Physicist.
Robust eyebrows.
White.
Wears glasses.
Short hair.
Round nose.
Yeah.
square head I hope nobody writes these for me I hope nobody
writes these sorts of like like what would you write for me
for my appearance oh my gosh thank you for the 20 thank you
for the 20 gifted you're a simp thank you Joshua you are
absolutely Jewel to Watch and I have been having so much fun
watching your streams.
Keep that idle heart shining mint.
Have you ever heard of the band called Bandmade?
I have.
I don't know a lot about them though which is funny you'd
think that they'd be like everything I love you know.
250489.
250489 and we know we called earlier so we know he's out.
He's good.
Dork shape head.
Stop!
Help!
Oh!
1958.
Ooh, here it's about to expire.
I'm a resident of the building.
I come from doing the shopping.
There he is.
For real.
He's retired.
Oh!
shopping has a mustache yep big nose yep goatee yep smokes
yep always wears a hat yep except in this picture how did
you convince him 964 516 964 516 Six, one, eight, four, six,
one, one.
I think we're all good.
And he was on the list, right?
Yep.
Oh, let me call his house.
Shoot.
Can you open the door for me?
Um, four, two, four, two.
Let me give me a second.
Sir.
Oh, oops.
I grouped the four and the twos together in my brain.
Liquid.
Nerd walk, lack of nose, Otaku stink, sinister demeanor.
Oh, my father is not at home.
Okay, cool.
Don't worry about this.
Just a note for future reference.
I hate this.
Get in there.
Go home.
How many more people do we have?
Oh!
Ever dream this clown?
Every night all over the world, hundreds of people see this
clown in their dreams.
If this clown appears in your dreams, don't play any game
with him.
If you want more information, go to nachogames.itio slash
unlikely.
It's an ad!
Hey!
Skip ad, skip ad.
Oh my gosh.
I can't believe I got an ad.
in our game.
Hello!
Marguerite Bubbles.
Yes, Marguerite Bubbles.
Your eyes are looking a little lazy.
It's okay.
It's probably your charm point.
0203.
She's a seamstress.
Curly hair.
Oh my god, it is!
Deviated left Hi!
It is actually a charm point.
Round nose.
Yeah.
Big smile.
Mm-hmm.
I'm not dreaming of the clown.
I'm dreaming of bubbles.
I said jumbles.
Is bubbles your dream, lady?
I'm dreaming of Margaret.
Bubbles.
What?
Oh, let me check her ID.
First.
103.268.
014.590.
I think she's good.
Enjoy the rest of your life.
I'm not brave enough to marry this woman.
She would make a man out of you.
Hello.
You're one of the sisters.
You're Celine's sister.
1980.
Wait, are you on the list?
Celine's sister.
I'm a resident of this building.
My apartment is on the 4th.
Is the 04 on the 1st floor?
She's...
Okay.
The mole is on the correct side.
She's got the earrings.
Okay.
Mole on right cheek.
Small pointed nose.
Yes.
Slim.
Long neck.
Okay.
She has a twin.
That's not an appearance.
That doesn't mean anything.
Let's try.
Six.
Nine.
What was the other sister's name?
Elise or Illinois?
Illinois's sister.
My sister is not at home.
Okay.
Oh.
Wine.
785-613.
269-514.
Sorry.
We're good.
Have a nice life.
What if I, I just shut, I locked the door in front of her.
Mm-hmm.
Oh!
Good afternoon, Mr. Albertsky Peach Man.
What is up with the peaches?
Why?
What, do they have a lot of money or something?
No.
Their name.
They are peaches.
They sound delicious.
That's why all the monsters want to impersonate and eat
them.
Peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches,
peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches.
I love you.
Um, we might want to ask him about the I thing.
Come from my job as a shoemaker.
Was he on the list?
No.
Um.
My appearance?
Yeah.
I just want to know...
I don't see anything strange with my appearance.
I can see it well with my one eye.
Mm-hmm.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Minto droopy eyes.
No nose.
Tiny cute dead.
Always wears a mid dress.
Until the day I don't.
That would be shocking.
Um...
I already answered your question.
I want to see if he gets a little upset, you know?
Like if he's just like, hey, come over here!
Maybe not.
I think it's time we...
Um, danger.
Thanks for the vibe, Captain!
Thank you!
3-3-0.
One, two...
Don't you roll your eye at me, Mint.
Yeah, don't roll your eye at me, mister.
Nice.
I'm gonna continue my job.
When will this day end?
Do you guys hear the...
I wanna know if it's part of the game or if you guys hear
like the buzzing also.
I can't tell if it's my headphones or not.
Good afternoon.
Where is your entry request?
Thank you.
Oh, you do hear the buzz?
Okay.
I think it's the game then.
I was worried it was my headphones.
You are not on the list.
Am I not on today's list?
Thanks for the gift, it's a hotball boy.
I think there is an error.
I should be on the list.
Look at the list again.
I don't see you on the list.
What's your name?
Arnold Schmidt.
I came...
my job as a writer you have the wrong mustache what's wrong
with my appearance look carefully at the photos of my papers
and compare them well with me this guy you are not slick I
love though that the actually like this doppelganger
actually went to like the department and was just like hey
um here to renew my id it was like i gotta get a new picture
a new new year new me new mustache 7 7 8 5 6 2 1 9 3 2 2
let's call home 5 1 2 3
people can change mustaches not here not in this 1955 that
is ridiculous that is absolutely absurd Gloria Schmidt
speaking yes where's your husband oh they're in the
apartment right now
you are you expecting a second husband are you sure you
don't want what's better than one
What if this is like, this is like her, uh, her like side
husband?
He, it looks the exact same.
She has a very specific type.
Just this guy has a silly mustache instead.
Goodbye.
Doppelganger.
Side husband.
Yeah.
Gosh, you guys are busy today.
Do we usually get this many, uh, this many, um,
doppelgangers?
No wonder I'm needed.
Wow.
Talon, thank you so much for that, Tony.
You have to thank you.
Hello, Steven.
My face?
Yeah.
A paper.
I don't know what you're saying.
I'm pretty sure we called this guy earlier.
I'm pretty sure he, like, because, uh...
Yeah, we had to call him to see about his dad.
Big nose.
Oh, whoops.
Wear sunglasses.
Not the smiley face emojis.
I thought you guys were, like, warning me about spoilers.
Okay.
Short hair, small hair.
Wait, what's wrong with the size of his head?
His head is normal.
What do you mean?
Ghost of mint!
Oh my gosh, wait, you're a ghost of a ghost?
That's crazy.
Thank you for the 10 gift, thank you.
What's wrong with the size of his head?
Four two, yes, remember, because I messed this up.
Four two, four two.
Ah, hmm.
Steven's speaking.
My father and I are in the apartment right now!
Are you not expecting a second self?
Hmm.
I'm going to give you one last shot, mister.
I want to see, actually, hold on, what if I do this?
I want to try this.
So is everything in order?
Can you open the door for me?
Oh, dang.
I thought like...
I thought something funny would happen, you know?
Alright.
Gosh.
These guys just need to remain on site, too.
Let them in.
We're playing the game proper now.
We'll have some fun, like, shenanigans stuff later.
Agree.
Oh, oops.
Skip.
Skip cleaning protocol.
Can't stop yawning.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
How much longer?
Oh!
100% accuracy.
Six dopples.
Neighbors killed zero.
Oh!
Rank S.
Easy!
Nice detail.
Hahaha.
Play again.
Skip, skip.
Goodbye, goodbye.
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Peach Man.
Good afternoon, Peach Man.
Give me your ID.
Yes, you forgot to show your ID.
Can't believe that Cyclops was a doppel.
They're really tricky, aren't they?
They really try to get you.
Let's see.
Albertsky Peach Man.
I'm arisen at this building.
home for my job as a shoemaker.
You're both shoemakers?
Oh, you both are actually shoemakers.
Let's see, your hair seems to be in order.
Your nose.
Yeah, yeah.
Prominent chin, very much so.
You have the big chin.
Your brother has the no chin.
What?
They don't write that in the appearance, though?
No chin?
I guess they have a little bit of a, a little bit of self,
or a little bit of respect for these for these for these uh
residents huh he looks too convincing let's check his
numbers one four six five one two one four six five one nine
eight six nine eight six three five four are you on the list
he is wow there's not so many people on the list today
yes Peter Griffin looking guy.
Don't be rude.
Good afternoon, Arnold Schmidt.
That's you.
Come from my job as a writer?
Wait, oh, all the apartments are different now too.
201.
Or I'm just going crazy.
He is a writer.
Oh, he is a writer.
778.566.
219.322.
Yep.
Big eyebrows.
Yeah.
Prominent mustache.
Where's a hat?
Round face.
Yeah.
Short hair.
The stash looks different.
No, it's the same.
And he's on the list.
Oh, you know what?
I forgot to call the previous person, didn't I?
Oopsie.
Whoopsie-poopsie.
5-1-2-3.
Let's try again.
Or let's try this.
We could have died first try.
First person.
Hmm.
I guess we'll see.
At the end of the day.
Gloria Schmidt speaking.
My husband is not at home.
Okay, good.
What if I try calling them right now?
You know?
What was the floor?
Where did that guy live?
Oh here.
Two six six eight.
Let's just try it.
Yeah let's try calling now.
Oh wait.
Oh they might be, if they don't pick up maybe they're dead.
Oh.
Oh my gosh!
He's alive!
My brother and I are in the apartment right now!
And there's an intruder!
Oh my god!
We're dead!
Ah!
Save us!
I think we're good.
Okay.
We just have to burn... It's like when you see a spider in
your room, you just have to...
42?
You just have to burn the whole place down?
42.
43.
Oh!
42, 42, 42, 42, 42.
Is this 42 ones?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
12 times 3.
Oh, 2, 4, 6.
36.
37, 38, 39, 40, 41, 42!
Who would have thought?
I think he means well.
He's quite obviously just trying to teach the youngins how
to count.
I've never seen Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy, so...
He's a man who knows what he wants.
42!
Not 41.
Not 43.
42.
Anyway.
Oh.
I just realized that the date actually didn't change, which
is kind of disappointing.
Thank you.
What are the trophies that I keep getting?
Are they under here?
Maybe on the menu.
When I was a part of hockey team, my number was 42.
No way.
Mm, hi or whatever.
Mm, hi.
Anastasia.
1985.
I live here, whatever.
I come from school.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, she's got it.
little seifuku so cute she's not on the list though ma'am
you are not on the list i'm not on today's list because i
had to leave due to an emergency or whatever what one was
she oh here tired eyes yeah two ponytails yeah small nose
round face She checks out.
1, 3, 2, 6, 9, 8.
5, 3, 4, 4, 6, 2.
Yeah, we're going to call our chef.
Wait, what if she's not there, though?
Okay.
1, 3, 4, 6.
Look, I'm the member.
Mooship, thank you!
Hello.
What?
My mother's...
Whatever.
Sneaky.
What if I say, like, ID?
My ID?
Are you gonna get mad at me?
A little doppelganger?
I don't see anything wrong with my ID.
Whatever.
Oh my gosh, she's even got her mannerisms down.
What's wrong with my appearance?
Everything is in order with my appearance.
Whatever.
My entry request?
I think everything's fine with my entry request.
Is that a zipper on her back?
This right here?
Let's check her picture.
No, she has it in the original too.
I think it might be maybe like the...
Maybe part of the backpack.
Like the handlebar of the backpack, you know?
Okay, anyway.
Three, three, one, two.
What's stopping these doppelgangers from just like climbing
the window?
You know?
Whatever.
That was tricky.
If we hadn't called...
Imagine, like, the first one!
The first one was completely fine.
If we hadn't called...
Well, I guess...
Well, he was on the list, actually, now I think about it.
Oh, my gosh!
Emma Stone!
Mia Stone!
Bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum.
Then, I came back from my job as a teacher.
Her hips don't lie.
Wow.
You are not on the list.
Am I not on today's list?
Must be a mistake.
I should be on the list.
No, you're not.
You're not.
Wait, who do you live with?
301?
Oh yes, of course.
How could I ever get W.
Afton?
She looks the exact same.
From what I can tell.
1-4-2-5.
Hmm.
The real giveaway for the last doppel was actually her entry
request was missing the DDD logo.
Oh!
Wait.
Who just picked?
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Was that Afton?
Sorry, I missed the name.
I was reading the comment.
Did he say Mia?
That was Afton?
Oh, okay.
Then, I guess she...
Okay, let's check the number.
789.
I need to be better about the DDD logos then, because I
didn't even notice at all.
Good eye.
789564.
525-115.
um lady make sure you properly get your stuff in order next
time for going out yes you need to properly get your stuff
in order it wasn't a mistake you didn't fill out the proper
paperwork but i'm gonna let you in
Hello, good day.
Where's your ID?
Sorry, here's my ID.
Yeah, I was about to literally call the police on you.
I was about to get your butt annihilated.
They were going to come in.
They were going to literally destroy you.
Reptilian.
Mm-hmm.
but you know i went out to visit my parents i mean she is on
the list long face big nose straight hair where's a headband
five six eight five five four five six eight five five four
five nine six three two nine let me call your home i must
talk to alf right away four two five eight four two Five,
eight.
The guy looks like he's like Bruce Wayne's Butler.
Like, my goodness.
Hmm.
Alph speaking.
My wife is not at home.
Okay.
Yes, maybe.
It could be some sinister beast waiting for you to trust it
so then it can pounce and suck.
all your blood from your body.
I forgot to show my entry request.
How long have you been living here, Robertski?
You forget to show your entry request every time.
I'm sick of this.
I'm just gonna...
But also, he's not on the list.
But yeah, it is missing the logo.
It's missing the logo.
I already answered your question Hmm One one wait One one
four six five two One one four six five two 289730 289730
Suss Sussie sussie The appearance looks fine But we must
call your your brother or I mean they do they kind of look
like they'd be brothers more than like lovers right I think
but isn't there a thing that some people like to date people
they look like or something or that's I don't know their
brothers Robertsky Peach Man speaking my brother and I are
in the apartment We are not expecting any visitors today.
Mm-hmm.
My entry request?
I think everything's fine with my entry request.
That's something a doppelganger would say.
I'm not on today's list because I had to leave due to an
emergency at work.
Likely story.
3, 3, 1, 2.
I think this game is relaxing so much it's making me so
tired.
Oh, sorry if you just heard me kick my mic.
Or rather I need it while I was adjusting.
Bust him.
Bust him!
I'm so sleepy today.
Next, please.
Wait,
didn't we see you earlier or...
Didn't we see you earlier?
One, four, two, five.
We did?
We just let her in?
Pick up.
Oh.
W.O.O.
Often speaking.
My fiance and I are in the apartment right now.
We are in the apartment.
We're not expecting any visitors today.
Uh.
Everything's the same.
As before.
Well, clearly that means there's two wives.
79.564.
425.
5115.
Clearly that means if I let both of them in, he'll be so
happy.
What's the difference in appearance?
Did I get the appearance on the other lady wrong?
Or is this the one that's the fake?
Uh-oh.
This all looks good, though.
This all looks good.
Oh.
Check the freckles.
They look the same.
Uh-oh.
Is the job right?
Yeah.
I checked the numbers.
Oh.
Let's check up again, 789, 564, 525, 115, yeah.
But I checked it last time, too.
I think we let the wrong Mia in.
Wait, but he would have been eaten, right?
Her birthday.
This isn't the birthday.
This is the expiration.
date because um sorry the chat's kind of blocking it but
it's currently february 1955 i just check the the expiration
make sure it's not call again one four two five four two
five oh my gosh am i gonna have to kill an innocent person
maybe yeah you're still alive They're in the apartment.
How?
I just want to know.
How would I know?
That this is the imposter.
They don't kill immediately?
Look at the logos.
I am.
I actually don't remember what the logo is supposed to look
like.
They don't give a reference, so I just have to believe that
this is the correct thing.
I think this is the real one.
I think so, too.
Try asking questions again.
My ID?
I don't see anything wrong with my ID.
What's wrong with my appearance?
Oh, you...
You...
The eyeshadow's not flattering on you.
Let them both in problem solved.
Either way, even if I...
If I call the DDD on this lady, she's gonna... She's gonna
die, so...
Yeah.
Okay.
You're welcome, Mr. Afton.
Now you have two wives!
Lucky you!
Good afternoon, why are you not on the list?
Now they both die.
If I had called the DDD on the lady standing here, she would
have died anyway.
So now, you know, they're all just, they'll all just, you
know.
That's just how the circle of life works.
Gloria Schmidt.
She's not on the list.
But she is a banker.
1974.
Round face.
Mole on right cheek.
The nose!
The nose is wrong.
What's wrong with my appearance?
Look carefully at my photos of my papers and compare them
well with me.
Oh, ma'am, I assure you I am.
sure you Gloria Schmidt of the bank I am doing that but I am
gonna call just in case I think there was a grammar error
when you asked about her appearance I'm inclined to believe
maybe that this the game dev is maybe not is maybe English
second language or something because there's been a lot of
grammar errors so i'm not kind of like putting that as a uh
as a uh thing
pop the button we woo we will we will
oh skip skip skip thank you sir thank you thank you very
much thank you call afton back you're right we should one
four two five Oh, I can't call yet.
Oh!
Heterochromia.
Good afternoon.
One second.
I have to make sure someone else is dead.
He's probably gonna be like, Look!
Dorman, I have two wives!
I'm the luckiest man on this world!
Wait, what is he gonna say?
My fiance and I are in the apartment right now.
We are not expecting any visitors today.
Interesting.
Wait, does she usually have...
It's Natcha.
0204.
Right eye blue.
Left eye green.
Wait, actually!
She does actually have heterochromia.
Curly hair.
Yeah, freckles, round face.
She looks good to me, but she's not on the list.
Mm-hmm.
More right or hers?
It has to be her right, right?
No, I'm pretty sure it's her right, because everything else
has said, like, mole on right cheek, and it's been correct.
it's her right
she's a chef I'm a resident of the building I come from my
job as a chef you can also kind of see it in the picture too
see like this looks darker and this one looks lighter her
nose is gone
789 655413 I'm so sorry that I'm yawning so much I don't
know why um one three four six
i don't know how we would have how we got the first mia
wrong i don't know nacho means butt cheek in spanish that's
so great my mother is not at home okay
how did we mess up how did we mess up i still think second
mia was was wrong.
I think you got the first Mia, right?
Really?
You think so?
You think maybe just because she was even though she was
perfect, she...
I don't know.
Oh, whoops, sorry.
What is underneath there?
What was that?
Um.
So, Some doppelgangers can be perfect.
They can?
Oh, well, I think he's really appreciative.
Wait.
Was it second floor?
There we go.
She looks right to me.
Even though you're not on today's list.
Can you tell me again why?
I think there's an error.
I should be on the list.
Oh, well.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, let her in.
I almost just murdered an innocent lady.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Good afternoon.
Oh, Angus.
Prime Beef.
565.
Wait, where are you at?
Oh, 103.
565.003.
698.
8845.
Yes, businessman.
Long neck.
Where's a hat?
Has a mustache.
Small eyes.
68.
DDD.
I'm a resident of the building.
I come from my job as a businessman.
And you are on the list.
I'm gonna call you Wait, no one else would pick up You're
the only one home Wait, what if I pick up and, or what if I
call and he's there Five Five One Three Brontosaurus Oh my
god, his teeth are like whales They look like, you know how
whales have like Oh yeah, he's not there
You know how whales have like Those really Like they look
like they look like really packed together hay barrels hello
peach man give me your id please yeah you did you forgot to
show your id now i'm even more suspicious of you
wasn't he here already he was wait where are you at oh one
oh two
We're not going to make the same mistake again.
Robert, ski peach man.
You and your brother?
My brother and I are in the apartment right now!
We are not expecting any visitors today.
And this one has no logo.
I'm not on today's list because I had to leave due to an
emergency at work.
likely story doppelganger
get exterminated what do they do with the doppelgangers why
do we have a doppelganger problem anyway
what kind of what what kind of What is it going on here?
Skinwalker Ranch.
Wow.
Good afternoon.
He looks like that one actor, Isaac.
He looks like John Stamos.
Is that his name?
Aliens.
Do you guys know that there is an alien ancient aliens like
the the tv show that there's a game can get it on steam i
thought about playing it he's a reporter big eyebrows big
smile prominent chin big nose why are you so rude to him are
you so stream it i've thought about it but it's one of those
types of games where it's like Okay, build this thing.
It's going to take, it's going to take 12 hours to build.
4, 5, 6, 9, 8, 5, 5, 1, 2, 3, 6, 9.
Hmm.
Resident of the building, my apartment's on the second
floor.
Second, second floor.
That's right.
Let's call just in case 7332.
7332.
12 hour waiting stream yeah well I'll do like I'll just I'll
just have it on in the background and we can be like okay no
ID?
No he has an ID he seems good I think
um it seems uh like at the end of streams we'll be like
where's our aliens at Wait, no date.
Oh, you're right!
Oh my gosh.
Things are not in order.
Things?
Let me checklist.
Uh-oh.
It will let me click the checklist again.
Um.
Is it because I already gave the okay?
You can still call.
Sorry if you were innocent.
Sorry.
Sorry if you were innocent, man.
But I don't think you were.
I think you had a fraudulent ID.
I think...
I think you're a doppelganger.
You're about to get exterminated.
They're about to like come in and literally set you on fire.
He was sus.
Hum.
Ah!
job as a reporter no what there it is four five six you guys
saved me before too i was so close nine eight five five one
two three six nine i was i was two seconds away from letting
him in you guys i was two seconds away
hello resent of the building i've come from my job as a
reporter good job team can you imagine this guy walking up
to his apartment and seeing a doppelganger of himself being
dragged out like i would i think i would tip the door man
i'd be like good job good job man siege thanks to the five
gift Thank you.
That would ruin my life.
No, I'd be like, good job, Dorman.
You're doing a good job.
Wait, so yeah, he's not there.
So, um...
Because we already called before.
Yeah.
Good job, team.
Oh, it's James.
Steven.
Where do you live?
303.
Oh gosh.
Big nose.
Wear sunglasses.
Short hair.
Small hair.
Or Thank you for the thank you.
Thank you.
Five, six, five, eight, four, five.
Five, six, five, eight, four, five, four, five, nine, six,
five.
Yep, Steven Red Boys.
And I know he's on the list.
Let's call up his place of residence, four, two, four, two.
Four, two, four, two.
Hey now.
I have a huge head.
You say that, Steve.
You say that.
My son is not at home.
Is he back?
I think so.
I don't know anymore after Mia.
I have no idea anymore.
I'm going to check his appearance one last time.
Yeah.
Okay.
42.
Nose?
What do you mean nose?
His nose was fine.
Ah!
Oopsie.
I was not better than that guy at the beginning.
Six dopples.
Wait, what do you mean?
Neighbors killed zero.
Mia fake documents.
Ah, what is Mia?
What is Mia?
Which one, though?
Which one?
Now aim for an F.
Actually, I do want to go to the menu.
Because, um...
Record?
Is that...
Oh, here we go.
Achievements.
Oh, wow.
You can get...
Wow.
B-C-D-E-F.
achievements oh look at that meet the clown discover the
secret of the universe finish one playthrough alive be
murdered get s rank on one playthrough better than henry
kill one neighbor wait how do i kill a neighbor since you
told me you read my letter i can't stop wondering what you
thought about it i hope i wasn't too embarrassing no it was
so nice thank you Yeah, it was so nice.
Oh, call DDD on someone innocent.
Got it.
Capture a hundred doppelgangers.
Survive without opening any folder?
Sounds impossible.
Complete Chester's quiz.
Who's Chester?
Survive 40 playthroughs.
Get F-rank on one playthrough.
Unlock all achievements.
Meet the peach doppelganger.
Catch a doppelganger red-handed.
Complete 100 playthroughs.
What's the peach?
Wait, did we not...
Peach is peaches.
Did we not meet the peach doppelganger?
We've got doppelganger of the peach bros.
Hmm.
Peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches,
peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches.
I love you.
Oh, whoa.
Peaches.
This, uh, I'm...
It sure would be something to 100% this game.
I know, right?
I think, uh, this one, steal memory.
That is not my...
That is not...
is rough for me like capture a hop hopl capture a hundred
doppelgangers is doable you just have to play the game a lot
I mean we're already at 12 so and 40 play-throughs I think
you can get both of these you know let's try again oh let's
try and at least get like the peach one and whatever the
quiz is i do i'm curious about that the ones that are like
the special doppelgangers i'm i'm most curious about and
then i guess they'll be adding more modes in the future
that'll be fun unless you unlock them when you get more
achievements that'll be fun though ian vivian welcome to
bamboo ship thank you bro thank you
Yeah.
Oh, we can skip this.
Hello.
Skip.
See ya.
Sayya.
This time, let's get an F.
Hello.
We have to get an F.
We have to get an F since it was the lowest and there were
so many in between we probably have to get every single one
incorrect.
Whoa, whee!
Full day!
Wow!
Which one is you?
Selene.
Every night in my dreams I see you, I feel you.
Selene has it on the right side.
Um, pointed nose, yeah.
Maybe, I don't know, I guess.
Long neck, short, twin.
So if this is correct, that means we call the cops on her.
Have, both have logos.
So seven, eight, five, six, one, three, two, six, nine,
five, one, four.
I think we need to call the cops on Celine Dion.
Oh, call the house.
Let's call the house.
6996.
9996.
Genocide run.
Yep.
So this time we are going for all inaccurate.
No one's home.
Get her out of here.
Good.
You will not survive here.
You will not ever see your family again.
Thank you.
Let's hope we get some obvious doppelgangers in here.
I like Roman.
We haven't seen you in a while.
I hope you're a doppelganger, so I don't have to kill you.
One, one.
Oh, yeah, you got that lucky, lucky, you're a lucky man, you
know that?
You're a lucky, lucky man, Mr. Roman Stiltsky.
Big nose, yeah.
Scar on right chin, yeah.
Long face, yeah.
One eyebrow, yeah.
Where's a hat?
You can't be correct.
He has an expiration date.
483-924-059-684.
No!
Oh wait, is he on a list?
Let's call his house.
1152.
Let's check.
It's a villager.
Ha.
Lois Stiltsky speaking.
No.
I'm not on today's list because I had to leave due to an
emergency at work.
You're an accountant.
What kind of an emergency would there be?
Hmm.
07.
The numbers were wrong?
No, they weren't.
They were?
4, 8, 3, 9, 2, 4.
0, 5, 9.
6, 8, 4.
They're all right.
Oh!
You mean the numbers?
You mean there was an accounting error?
Not an error from me!
Oh man.
07.
Have your doppelganger come back.
Emergency accounting.
I have contacted the day, day, day.
Say a lighter.
There was an emergency he didn't account for.
Good afternoon.
Gloria, Gloria, round face, mole on the right cheek, short
hair, round nose, you're looking perfect today, Gloria, I
might have to call the cops on you.
Job is a banker.
I work at the bank.
Can their names be written wrong and stuff?
I wonder how small the details go into, you know.
He didn't really excel today.
Oh.
He didn't calculate how poor this would be for him.
Boo.
Ah, thank you guys.
Thank you.
I knew you'd love it.
Boo, boo.
Yes, yes!
Boo!
Thank you, I knew you guys would love it.
69A522
341 150 I have to make an O emo to go with the B.
I do, I do, I do.
Let's see.
Hello, Arnold Schmidt speaking.
My wife is not at home.
Is she back?
Oh, she's back all right.
She's back to jail.
Oh.
She's back to...
Um...
Back to being a baby.
In...
In the tummy.
It's like she was never born.
Yet.
Or ever again.
Hello.
Can I have your ID please?
Thank you.
Mr. Robertski.
Are you on the list?
You are.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
The game is glitching again.
It will let me click on his file.
Shoemaker, we know that.
Like, I don't know what his phone number is.
Hold on.
Oh.
I think it's 2-6-6-8.
Oh, whoops.
I'm going to trust you.
2-6-6-8.
Oh.
You were right.
Wait, Albertsky.
My brother's not at home.
Yeah, because he's Albertsky and he's Albertsky.
Peachman, Peachman.
Yes.
Thank you.
Okay.
So we knew he was out.
DDD.
We got the expiration date.
It's good.
His appearance looks fine to me.
I think I remember what he looks like.
We know he's a shoemaker.
Get out of here, Peach Man.
Can I undo this once I... Oh, I can.
Okay, that's kind of nice.
Just kidding.
This guy is just like, No, please don't kill me.
No!
No, God!
Oh, God, please!
I'm just kidding, Robert Sicky.
I'm not kidding.
Death to you!
Death to you, Peach Man!
And he's behind there.
He's like, no, please!
Oh, God, Sparrie's, please!
Oh, Sparrie!
I'm just kidding.
Oh, my gosh.
It's just a prank, bro.
It's just a prank.
Oh, no, never mind.
Off with his head.
Do you get anything for making more ghosts?
Like commission?
Fortunately, no.
Actually, the afterlife is kind of crowded.
I don't think they want more ghosts.
Alrighty.
Next person, please.
Hello.
I think we killed your sister.
earlier.
oh my gosh.
Wait, we can't click the first floor anymore at all?
Oh, the game is so bugged.
Um, nice.
Uh.
Does anyone know her, her phone number?
She might actually be a doppelganger.
I don't know.
I can't tell.
I don't remember which side the mall is supposed to be on.
No job.
She's a model.
I remember that.
Vivi Kourt, thanks for the gifted.
It's 3-3-1-2.
Thank you.
Thank you guys for helping.
She's on the list.
You guys tricked me.
Hi!
Oh, her picture would be on the list, you're so right!
Oh wait, it looks just like her.
Yeah, Illinois.
6996!
How could I forget?
Thanks, 6J and Kyoma.
Thank you.
They're not there?
Wait.
Oh wait.
No.
Because I killed the sister before, it would make sense that
nobody's home.
Right?
And her little Ahoye is going in the right direction.
Did he just make these characters and flip them?
I put 69, 69.
Wait.
9?
6.
9.
Oh my god.
Oh, I need to sleep properly tonight for real.
I'm going to have trouble tomorrow.
Okay, it's the same reaction, though.
I think I'm just going to have to kill her.
Oh, God.
Let the sisters be together.
Exactly.
Thank you.
Oh, he's still talking.
I need some more tea.
Okay.
Bye-bye.
See you later.
Next person, please.
Good afternoon.
Where is your entry request?
I'm already sussy of you.
Mia Stone.
I think she is on the list.
Yeah, 301.
Looks the same.
Let's count the freckles.
One, two, one, three, now,
three, now, four, five, six.
eyebrows, oval face, she's a teacher, indeed she is, Emma
Stone.
Let's call 1 4 2 5.
1 4 2 5.
You know what annoys me even more about those who got me
with the 3 3 1 2 being the twins' For the fact that I so
sincerely thanked you guys for helping me.
I was just like, oh my gosh, thank you guys.
Because the game is glitching for me, I can't check myself.
You guys are so awesome for helping me out.
I so sincerely thanked you being like, my, you know, wisps
are so great.
They're so helpful and kind.
You know, glyphs, I don't want to see that.
I want to see that from you.
One guide hard.
It was two people!
It was two of them.
I got two guide.
Let's see.
Appearance seems fine.
789564.
789.564.
525.115.
525115.
Mia Stone.
I hope you said some Thanks to your husband tonight.
I mean last night.
I mean this morning What is wrong with me?
Anyway, okay, you know what?
Let's just send her away.
Let's just get her out of here.
Low on brain juice.
Oh my gosh.
I was just I think because it's tonight like for me you know
it's night so I was just like yeah tonight you better have
said but I was just trying to say like the last time you saw
him you should have you I'm oh do your ears hang low do they
wobble to and fro can you tie them in the night can you tie
them in a bow can you throw them over Why would you hand
this to me, Francis?
What happened to your ears?
My ears?
I spread them out to hear better.
Make sense to me.
Have a nice day, Francis.
Can you throw them over your shoulder?
Like a something, something.
Hello.
Uh-oh.
Oh, we can tie it.
We can click it again.
Nice.
Um, Selene is right or left side.
She escaped.
Oh, no, she's a perfect...
The third lost child.
The mole on entry is wrong?
What do you mean?
No, it's correct.
because she's Celine.
Her name is spelled wrong.
No, it's not.
It's correct.
How am I supposed to know which one was the right?
Okay.
Okay, I'm going to make an educated guess here.
What?
It's missing an S.
Oh, her last name!
Subvert, subvert, oh!
My ID?
I don't see anything wrong with my ID.
Well, okay, this was gonna be my educated guess anyway.
This was going to be my educated guess that she was the
doppelganger anyway.
Because, say we let the first two in, because they were
correct, was so perfect.
Well, it would have had to been the doppelganger.
You know?
Anyway.
Bye-bye.
Oh, Oh.
Hmm.
I don't...
Oh, she is on the list.
That's why she went outside.
Because she was on the list.
Have a nice day.
Oh, no, she's French.
Good afternoon.
Good afternoon, Angus.
See, Priya.
Well, okay, you know what?
I did ask earlier, I think, if the name's going to be
misspelled.
And that answers my question, doesn't it?
The person before.
What do you mean by that?
103.
Long neck.
Where's a hat?
Has a mustache and small eyes.
He's a businessman.
565.
003.
69845.
Looks good to me.
me.
Except.
Oh, sir.
Oh, no, sir.
You are quite suspicious.
If I do say so myself, but I will call your home and see.
Five, five, one, three.
Oh,
I thought someone picked up for a second.
I wouldn't trust anyone with that smile.
Look, you can't judge a book by its cover, okay?
This guy, he's just Angus Capriani.
Wait, what floor was he?
Oh, first floor.
Angus Capriani.
You are under arrest for tax evasion.
So far, I think we're doing pretty well.
I think we're doing well, you guys.
I think we're going to get this F for sure.
I think we're going to get it for sure.
You can continue your job.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Here, boss, I'm taking responsibility for accidentally
gaslighting you
I hope you can get some well-deserved rest after the stream
is over and have a great weekend.
You too!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
We got Francis back.
He's a milkman.
He's on the list.
Heretic, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Alright, let's check your...
numbers 2355 2355 6941 6941 8995 his expiration date is good
he's a ddd
i just let you in earlier actually francis so um what are
you doing back here hmm i just let you in let's make sure
like the nose and stuff though because some of these tiniere
details could probably get us tripped up if we think that
they're fine but they're actually
not but i think with this one we're good i am 100 not baked
i saw this super chat
cleaning protocol completed continue your job yes sir thank
you sir see you later sir Oh my gosh, you're back!
Yes, you!
Of course, the mom!
Natcha!
Natcha, how are you doing today, Natcha?
Oh.
I mean...
Yeah?
Natcha, I mean, usually people just say, I'm fine.
No need to trauma dump on me or anything.
I get it.
Alright, let's just let her in.
Let her have a...
You know, get some rest nacha!
Those will heal eventually.
Don't worry.
Reptillion.
Capacino.
I'm arisen in this building.
I went out to visit my parents.
three oh four she's a housewife long face big nose straight
hair where's a headband yeah looks looks pretty right to me
looks pretty good she's on the list her numbers five wait
raf tell raf raf dylan capuchin five six eight five five
four five six 5.5-4.
5.9-6-3-2-9.
62.
She's too perfect.
Didn't this lady show up earlier?
Did she?
I can't remember.
The games are bleeding into each other.
I'm interested in what would happen if you call since you
let her other in.
Let's try it.
Who is it?
1-3-4-6.
Three, four, six.
Yeah, see, we just let her in.
Oh, she wasn't on the list.
For some reason, I was confusing her with Natcha, so I was
like, wait, but you were on the list for real, actually.
Hey, Mintz, it's my friend Chris's birthday.
It would make him very happy if you could sing him Happy
Birthday.
Also, Simba, thank you for that birthday gift.
Thank you so much.
Happy birthday.
Hold on.
Okay, one more time.
One more time.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Chris.
to you.
Yay!
Happy birthday.
This lady looks good, doesn't she?
Lots of lots of humans today, eh?
Ugh, it's exhausting.
Really giving the DDD a run for their money.
Wait.
Humans, it's my friend Chris's birthday.
It would make him very happy if you could sing him happy
birthday.
What?
It's definitely not the same Chris.
Huh?
Can't you use the same one though?
What?
Yeah, is it a doppelganger Chris?
Does your Chris have a mole on his left side or his right
side?
Hello, Nacha.
Actually, I feel like we can automatically let this lady in.
Because we already called before and we saw that Natcha was
at home.
You know?
Right eye blue.
Left eye green.
No DDD.
Oh, you're right.
No DDD logo.
Let her in.
Yeah, we'll just let her in.
What's in bad?
Thank you for another 50!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Oh my goodness, you guys have gotten insane with the
members, don't knows, everything.
This lady, she looks different.
Ah!
Her mouth is down.
I want to ask.
What's wrong with my appearance?
She looks different.
Look carefully at the photos of my papers and compare them
well with them.
I don't remember where she lived.
Oh, wait.
You also didn't give me your entry request.
Here's my entry request.
Thank you.
304.
Yeah, see, even it's supposed to be way up.
It's supposed to be way, way up.
Lady!
Have a nice day!
Mm-hmm.
This is an easy job.
Mr. Hofton.
71.
The DDD.
Pharmacist.
Wait, where did you live again?
Oh, 301.
Physicist!
Oh!
Wait.
Oh, physicist.
I think I'm regressing.
you know it took a lot of energy going from heaven back to
manifesting as a ghost but you know maybe i'm losing so much
ghostly energy that i'm reverting back into like a like a
wisp thanks for singing for me i was too shy to ask myself
and your fans are absolutely evil in the nicest way possible
of course chris if that's really you free supas now First
name is Dr. W.
Absolutely, Dr. W.
Afton.
All right, 250.
489.656.
214.
And I'm pretty sure he was on the list.
So him being out would make sense.
I think we've called even.
1425.
Five.
Nope.
I think we're good to deny.
Three, three, one, two, that's the call.
You are never coming back home.
Those don't rhyme, but that's okay.
I won't survive the end of the day.
Three, three, one, two.
Oh!
You again!
Oh my gosh, your place is gonna be so crowded, madam.
Reptilian.
Your appearance.
Oh, that's right.
What's wrong with my appearance?
I'm just saying.
Yeah, I did.
I already answered their question.
Three times.
Okay.
Works for me then.
She's so popular.
She's the beauty standard.
Okay.
Moment of truth.
F!
F, F, F, F, F, F.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, dead.
People killed.
Yeah!
Oh, yeah!
Yippee!
Oh, not just, I was like, scar.
All right!
Let's go!
Seven is crazy.
I know.
We killed 10 people.
Nice, nice, nice.
That should also give us another record too, though, right?
If we go back to the menu.
Wow.
Yeah, kill an innocent neighbor.
Get the F.
Let's go, baby.
What is...
I still want to get Peach.
doppelganger red-handed how how do you do that
scar is an interesting way to say entire face stitched shut
right
you ask questions oh by questioning them oh okay okay okay
let's try um a few more maybe we'll get peaches or maybe
these are kind of they're kind of longer so I don't mind
that I kind of like that they don't it doesn't necessarily
need a story it's just kind of like you play all right nice
now we're playing again for real wait there was also the
what was it the one where you don't touch any folders.
So basically I can't touch any of these, right?
And I have to...
Right?
I said no folders, so...
I'm assuming I can look at this.
Steel memory.
Uh-oh.
What was his phone number?
Wait!
Whoa, Mr. Afton!
What was your phone number?
I'm a resident of the building.
I'm not on today's list because I had to leave Dudo at an
emergency at work.
3-3-1-2, you're not gonna get me this time.
1971.
No logo!
No logo, no logo!
No logo, no entry, mister.
No logo, no entry!
Hmm, hmm.
Nice.
This is like evil Animal Crossing speak.
Like anti-animal crossing, anti-cute.
Oh, oh!
Oh no!
Romans, Tilsky, what happened to you?
What happened to you?
I don't mean to...
I mean, it's a little...
I look like I always do.
It's a little rude to say, like, Hey, what's wrong with your
face?
But, you know, it's just kind of like a...
It's just a little, you know...
Poor guy went to the doctors today and we're sending him to
jail.
He's just like, please, I don't feel so well.
I just want to go home and relax.
Thank you.
He wasn't even on the list.
Hello, Peach Man.
Good afternoon.
Shoemaker, yes.
list he is he is on the list we can't confirm his uh his his
id number but you okay man yeah i'm okay i'm all good i
think we're just gonna have to i think we're just gonna his
nose looks like it wait
nope everything seems according to as it should be thank you
for the raid hello I believe this is correct I think so I
think we're good
doing our best here without the folders.
Okay.
Good afternoon.
Arnold.
We remember that he is always wearing a hat.
1971.
Got the logo.
Murphy, thanks for the 10 gifted.
All according to Japanese word for plan.
Keikaku.
Means plan.
Oh, was he a writer?
Or did he work at the bank?
I work at the bank.
Who was the accountant?
Roman is the accountant.
And I think Arnold's wife is the banker.
He is a writer.
Getter, thanks for the five gifted.
Ducky, thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, I think we're just going to have to let this guy in
then.
He's on the list too, right?
Yep.
201.
So everything is in order?
I hate people that work at the bank.
I work at the bank.
Takis, thanks for the vibe, Captain.
Little Luhu, thank you for the 50.
Fun comics, thank you for the 5.
Why?
Oh, Sean, thank you for the 10 turtles.
Thank you for the 20.
Okay, let's just let him in.
Do you have to get a perfect run to get the achievement?
You do, yeah.
Hello.
Oh, gosh, we haven't seen this lady.
Like, we've only seen her, like, one time.
But we can compare her appearance with this.
Looks good.
Looking good, Lois, and Joko.
Joko's, thank you for the 10.
KVAR, thanks for the five.
McVack, thanks for the 10.
Tag out.
Guys, Lois, Stinky.
1969.
I'm a resident of this building.
I went out to visit my mother.
We got the DDD logos.
Yeah, thanks for the five.
Stingy.
I think she's good.
From what we can tell, I think she's okay.
That's all we can try.
Patkun takes her to the 10.
Hello.
Margaret.
Missa Bubbles.
Shin, thanks for the 10.
Kenja takes her to the 5.
Thank you guys.
Let's see.
Day, day, date.
1975.
We haven't got, we've had the expiration date missing, but
we have not had it incorrect.
Day, day, day.
I went out for my job as a seamstress.
Is she a seamstress?
I don't know.
I don't, I don't remember if she was a seamstress or not.
Also, let's check her nose.
Her nose is good.
Her face is good.
My brow's good.
Seam stressed.
That is actually so true of seam stresses.
You are not on the list.
Oh gosh.
Uh-oh.
And to leave due to an emergency.
Why is it?
glitching out.
I think it is correct though, her eye color.
I can't remember her nose at all though.
I can't remember her nose.
Oh nose, oh nose, oh nose, oh nose.
I came for my job as a chef.
What kind of chef emergency was there?
I keep thinking the flying dust in the game is my dirty
screen.
Wrong nose it is.
We don't have a reference over here.
And we also can't call because probably her daughter's out.
Kiyoma, thanks for the 10.
Ellie, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I don't think their nose is wrong.
She should be in though if you call.
Oh, true, true, true, true.
No, she was a chef.
She was a chef for sure.
It's Emma Stone that's a teacher.
Okay.
Does anybody remember the phone number?
Oh, question her more.
Oh.
My ID?
I don't see anything wrong with my ID.
Okay.
A parent.
What's wrong with my parents?
She seems so happy about me, like, really interrogating her.
I'm a little...
I enter your request.
I don't see anything wrong.
wrong with my entry why did she say the same thing every
time nanoplasm thank you i was just wondering if you got
your moguls minted
moguls minted i don't remember the rest
i think she's good i think hopefully I should probably have
changed it so that if you get it wrong, it kills you
immediately.
So we don't have to suffer through the entire thing.
Oh!
Hi, or whatever.
Give me your ID.
I forgot to show my ID.
Whatever.
Anastacha.
Okay, we got the DDD.
1995.
DDD.
I live here, whatever.
I come from school.
We do know that she is a student.
whatever whatever whatever 204 204 Anastasia Anastasia
Mikael Mikael
she looks she looks good every little single hair is in
place oh my gosh imagine you had to actually like style your
hair the same way every day you had to literally put the
same little like little strand of hair you know yeah
i think i'm gonna let her in
i think i'm gonna let her in every single tiny strand of her
hair
Hopefully.
Hair stranding.
Oh, hello!
Good afternoon, Angus.
Okay.
He's a businessman.
We didn't know that about you.
I'm nervous because I feel like we're not catching a lot of
things, you know?
I feel like we're...
I don't know.
It looked like I'm picking his teeth.
Um.
Oh.
A businessman with a business plan.
Chris is doppelganger!
Hello.
Um.
Wait.
How do I know you're a doppelganger?
Anyone can say that they're the doppelganger.
But.
How will I know?
Prove yourself wrong.
Uh, 3-3-1-2.
I think we just gotta let this guy in.
Next.
Good afternoon, old man.
Wait, I don't know you at all.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I don't...
Oh, no, it's Alf!
We've never met Alf before!
Uh-oh.
Maybe it's too hard to do the steel difficulty.
We don't know, Alf.
Am I not on today's list?
You are not!
I think there's an error.
I should be on the list.
Look at the list again.
Are you saying that I made a mistake, Mr. No date?
You guys are so good.
Nice.
Get out of here, Alfie boy.
Yes.
Squeaky clean.
As if he were never here.
Not even a single debris.
of flesh left.
Hello, where's your ID?
Here's my ID.
Miss Illinois.
Okay, we got the day, the D, D, D.
Let's make sure the name is spelled correctly.
It's for Yep.
Job is a model.
Resident of the building.
I think so.
Goodbye, Monopoly Man.
Does the Monopoly Man not have an iPod or a monocle?
It's not like one of those Mandela effect things.
She's got the mole on the right side.
She's looking good.
He never did.
Yeah, he never had a monocle.
But a lot of people think...
You had one.
Thanks, K-Barn!
Silly chat.
Supas aren't free.
Stream labs, though, are totally free.
I think she's good.
It's hard when you can't call to confirm that the person's
there or not.
Oh!
Milkman, milkman, milkman.
Did you stretch them to here?
Oh my gosh, thank you.
Welcome to membership.
Stop.
Thank you so much.
Bunny for Sona Bag.
I want to nibble on those.
When people say they like big ears, this is what they mean.
Pointy ears are a thing of the past.
It's all about the lobes now.
We're here for long lobes.
Long lobes.
Yeah!
Oh, that cartilage, baby!
Sorry.
Last time I was able to let you in, but this time I must
reject you, Mr. Lobes.
I prefer...
pointy ears no no don't you see him and don't you feel a
little excited there's something in you that stirs something
you didn't recognize before something you were like hmm this
is new this is different but i don't hate it i think in fact
i like it good afternoon steven red boys
A pilot.
Wait, date.
D-D-D.
Steven Red Boys.
Go on in, goose.
I heard supers were free, so here's why.
You have heard incorrectly, Raisin, but thank you.
Who?
What is the meaning of life?
the universe and everything else.
Oh, 42!
That's correct!
What is the scientific name of the Australian animal that
drastically changes its appearance when removed from its
natural habitat?
Oh, this is the quiz!
Oh my gosh, we got the quiz!
Huh?
Camellia?
I thought.
Is a chameleon Australian?
The drop bear.
Octopus?
Oh my gosh, the audio is getting kind of freaky.
Scientific name.
Made mint.
Quick to Google.
Okay, Google, Google, Google.
scientific scientific name of the Australian oh my gosh
the Australian animal that drastically changes its
appearance when removed from its habitat is the echidna
scientifically known as the is the echidna sonic hedgehog
tatachi tatachi
Aeculiatus.
No!
But this was an expert verified answer from Google!
This is the dog.
No way.
Oh, man.
I think it was the blobfish.
Why not just Echidna?
Because it said the scientific name.
Oh.
Well, we tried the quiz.
We got the quiz.
So that's cool.
We at least got that part.
Glad.
No, you're not.
on the list.
Selene.
Selene, they're not on the list.
Wait a second.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, yeah, it's Eleanor.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
I think we got a not let her in.
I think we need a not let her in.
1980.
The mole.
No, no, no.
They're twins.
They're two different people.
You have Celine and the other and Illinois.
They're two.
They're twins.
The nose.
The nose!
You're so right.
What's wrong with my appearance?
I mean, I think everything is fine with my appearance.
Hey, I'm Mint and Chat.
What's your favorite ice cream flavor?
Mine is chocolate chip mint ice cream.
So have a fantastic weekend.
Chocomito, ice, ice, ice.
Uh, my favorite.
Hmm.
I think I really like...
It depends on if I'm in a fruity mood or a milky mood.
I really like Oreo ice cream.
Oreo's so good.
But I also like mint.
chocolate mint yeah it's so funny because a lot of people
draw me as like ice cream but that was never really my
intention because especially with like my you know original
look I was never so you know my name's mint and I wear a lot
of mint but I was never mint chocolate and then with this
outfit I only added a little bit of chocolate motifs but a
lot of people draw me as ice cream
What'd she say?
Oh, sorry.
I was not paying attention.
What'd you say, lady?
I didn't...
What?
You said check it again?
Whatever.
I think we should not let her in.
Because, Mia Stone, you did not put your thing about being a
teacher.
Oh, emergency at work.
No stamp here!
Oh, no stamp here!
It's so confusing because I put the stamps here.
So, like, I instinctually think that the stamps are going to
be there.
You know what I mean?
Three, three, one, two.
Mint Oreo ice cream is next level TBH.
Oh.
Let's get...
They draw you as ice cream because you're so cool?
Ah, thanks.
Hey, Mint, Chris's wife here.
Have you seen him?
He's running away.
No, I didn't let the doppelganger in.
What?
No!
Who was it?
Ah, just one.
Natcha!
You guys did say the nose.
You guys did say Natcha's nose.
You did say... That was so close.
That was so close.
Natcha, Natcha neighbor, for real.
But we did get an A.
Dang.
It was the nose.
I should have known Nosed because you guys are experts You
guys are nose experts apparently I really want to see
peaches So let's try one more time Let's try one more time
And we're going to also try The memory thing as well Here
Last run LG, LG, LG
Hello Hello Oh my my gosh it's a full roster and maybe we'll
get the quiz guy again too
i came from my job as a model and the logo and the date yes
yes yes i think that we're good she's also on our list 104
104 yep
Thing was the blobfish.
I know, everybody's been saying that.
Oh, hello.
Good afternoon.
McCluey Red Boys.
He's always wearing his hat.
It said that.
The thing, we got a date.
We got a stamp.
Got some numbers.
Can't tell if they're right or wrong.
We have no idea.
His nose seems right.
His mustache seems right.
Everything seems correct.
Doing some shopping.
He's retired, so that makes sense.
He's got the stamp.
Ask to remove his hat.
Can I do that?
Remove your hat, sir.
Okay.
I think he's good.
Mcloy.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's his name.
Hello, milk.
Man.
Your nose.
That is not your nose.
That is not the correct nose.
No.
No, no, no, no, no.
That is not your nose.
That is not his nose.
I know.
It was not his nose.
His nose was not so defined.
I'm almost positive.
I'm like, check his file.
No, we're doing a run where we don't check the files.
That was not his nose.
I know it, I know it, I know it.
Um, hello?
Uh, entry request?
Uh, oh, uh, not on the list?
Due to an emergency?
What kind of emergency?
Selene?
Muddle.
But no, you said emergency.
The mole?
No, no.
That's the sister.
It's the sister.
Wee-woo!
Yeah, there's the sister Selene and the sister Ellen...
Something.
Ellen...
Illinois.
Illinois, yeah.
Okay, nice.
Good job, everybody.
Oh, hello.
Your ID, sir?
Hello.
Oh, he got back from his lobotomy.
That must be it.
XLR8.
You're not...
Oh, sir, you're not on today's list.
Am I not on today's list?
There must be a mistake.
I should be on the list.
Look at the list again.
Lobotomy, lobotomy.
My forehead?
Yeah.
It's nothing.
Just ignore it.
Doorbar...
I got that Suguru hair like...
Stop.
Learn a thing and talk to me.
Satoru.
When you listen, I was gone.
Wait, no, Gojo.
Satoru.
Hello!
You are always out.
Mr. Angus.
Oh, um, ID, please.
Don't make me sob.
1968.
Moustache appearance seems typical.
Uh, stamp.
Angus Ki-Priani.
Oh no.
I think we're good.
I think he's good.
The tie?
No, it's good.
No job.
I don't think they have to say it every time, do they?
I don't think they say it they have to say it every time
I think we're good
bye-bye next please
uh-oh uh-oh
uh-oh uh uh-oh
Uh-oh.
The apartment?
Oh my gosh, that's so sneaky.
Wait, no, it's correct.
It's correct.
Wait.
Oh, 30.
Oh, wow.
That's really sneaky.
Oh, that is so sneaky.
Sorry, number is really confused me.
Yeah.
You almost got God, girl.
I know.
Well, I would have reported him anyway because we already
let the other guy in.
So I would have sent him away anyway.
Thank you.
Next.
Get over here.
Oh.
Good afternoon.
Where's your ID?
Yeah, you did forget to show me your ID.
a stone.
Big mistake.
Okay, we got a date.
We've got a we've got a stamp.
We've got some names.
Now I have to worry about other things that I didn't even
think about having to check before.
She's a teacher.
Yes, she is.
We got a stamp.
Oh, 301.
I think I think I think she's good.
Wait, we didn't let her in earlier, did we?
I don't think we did.
I don't think we let her in earlier.
I think we'll...
I think we're good.
No?
Hold on.
Everything is...
I can't tell if it's my internet or why.
Everything's starting to stutter a little bit.
Alright, let's let her in.
Previous run.
The runs are really fusing together.
They are.
Rish.
Hello.
ID.
Yeah, this is...
It's like starting to lag a little bit.
Okay.
Gloria, this is our last run, so...
Oh my gosh, I thought that was a mole?
I was like, the mole's on the rock side!
No seams up to par.
Yes.
Date, stamp, date, 0201, 0201.
I think we have to let her in.
I thought so too.
I know, right?
Next!
Next, next, next!
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
you guys come in together?
Date.
Let's check your appearance.
You got your handlebar mustache.
Very good.
You got your little hat on.
Job is a rider.
Yes, that's correct as well.
I'm gonna have to let you in.
Hopefully I didn't oversee anything.
Hopefully I didn't miss something.
Next!
Hello!
I think we were right though Um Why are you not on today's
list Um There must be a mistake I should be on the list I
don't think so I don't see you We've got a date We've got a
stamp No stamp here No go madam Security Security Get this
one She is a disturbing me.
Please, I feel unsafe.
Thank you.
Bustin, Bustin, Bustin.
Next.
No mole.
Oh my god, it's the hidden sister.
It's her.
It's her solidus!
What's wrong with my appearance?
I think everything's fine with my appearance.
Think again.
Oh, do you even think?
Here's my entry request.
Wow, she forged it really well.
She's got the stamp and everything.
Yep.
No moles, yep, no moles, no go.
Okay, Miss, Miss Eleanoy's.
Yeah, little do we know she went, she's coming back from the
doctors.
She's just like, oh, I just had the worst day.
Like, getting this mole removed was so much more painful
than I imagined it to be.
I forgot to tell the entrance, but I'm sure they'll
recognize me they'll let me in it's no big deal and we send
her to jail or to die i don't know do they die or they good
afternoon where's your entry request thank you me yes didn't
we let me a stone in before already
uh oh this one wait
yes we did
the second wife
the second the second wife 1978
I hope it wasn't like the numbers were wrong they're like
the ID numbers because there's no way I'm a resident of the
building I come from my job as a teacher anyone could know
that anyone could know me as stone's a teacher You creepy
doppelganger.
I guess we'll just have to not let her in, I think.
Yeah, I think we just have to not let her in.
The last one had...
No logo?
If that was the last one, I'm going to cry.
You bitch!
Get out of here!
Get out of here with your round face.
I don't want to see you.
No!
I can't believe we messed up.
I should have...
I should have kept track.
I should have kept track of whether I...
Old man!
Oh, please.
Oh, I don't even feel like...
I don't even feel the motivation anymore.
Rip run, yeah.
He seems fine.
It doesn't matter anyway.
Just let him in.
How many people are left?
No, you always have your hat on!
Roman!
Wait.
I want to ask him about it.
Oh, my appearance.
Is it because of my hat?
I forgot it.
He didn't call my apartment and ask my wife.
Wait, I didn't expect that answer.
I thought he said he'd, like, lose it or something.
No way.
You left it at home?
That sounds like a reasonable answer.
This can happen?
He doesn't have a wife.
Oh, yes, he does.
And this is a lucky man.
Have you seen his wife?
Good golly.
She's got...
And she also has...
And a ton of...
Cool.
1.152.
Thank you guys.
Lois Dilsky is speaking.
My husband is not at home.
Did he forget his hat?
His hat?
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes, he is.
You left a year!
I almost... I almost sent you to die, Roman.
I almost sent you to die.
Have a good day.
How many are left?
Peach Man.
You, me of stone.
I'm never watching La La Land again.
I'm a La La Land auntie now!
Oh yeah.
Oops.
Everything about the appearance seems fine.
I don't know why I'm still caring.
Maybe I'm hoping for a miracle.
Something.
Going.
Oh no date.
He fell down the stairs.
He left something in his car, obviously.
He had to run out really fast.
Go grab it.
Wait,
so I also let a guy in?
Neighbors killed one.
Wait, who did I let in then?
Mia,
fake documents.
Mia.
Oh god, the game is like starting to lag so bad.
I think we let in fake Mia.
So frustrating.
It's harder.
It's, of course, harder when you can't see the records.
But I mean, honestly, we did a pretty good job for...
I think we just mixed up the Mia's.
Well, we did a pretty good job for not having the records to
be able to reference to, so...
I think we killed... I think we killed the correct Mia.
And we... accidentally let in the bad Mia.
I think.
Mama Mia.
Well, that was fine.
Thank you guys for catching some ghastly ghouls with me
today.
Let's see.
What achievements do we have left still?
There's no A.
There's only S and F.
Oh yeah, Chester's quiz.
40 playthroughs.
Which we did not survive the past couple ones.
That's okay.
Toppleganger red-handed.
Uh.
Yeah, it's this one.
Survive without opening any folder.
Wait.
All we have to do is survive, right?
So we kill all of them.
Doesn't that technically mean...
Will survive?
I should have chosen a different username.
Every time you said, meh, this stream, I got jumpkin.
Sowie.
That works, it does.
We die if a doppel gets in.
Yeah, but if we just don't let anybody in, then it should be
fine.
Right?
You know what?
One more!
Let's try it.
Let's cheat the system.
This one should be fast because we're just killing
everybody.
Blood, blood, blood!
Yes!
Death to you!
Oh, wait!
If we can catch a guy red-handed, that would also be another
thing, right?
No, you seem safe, though.
No survivors!
Kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill,
kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill,
kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, you
are on the list, um, see, that's his nose.
That's his nose, you guys.
The other nose had too much definition.
There was, like, little holes and stuff for him to breathe,
but he doesn't have those to breathe.
He's a mouth breather.
No logo?
It doesn't matter.
We're not going to let him in anyway.
We're not letting in a single person.
Is this the milkman that Tumblr is going wild for?
What do you mean by that?
Is Tumblr still a thing?
Good afternoon.
Doesn't this guy normally wear a hat anyway?
Is it because of my hat?
Yes, actually.
Oh.
I'm not gonna do that.
It's okay, he lived a long life.
People are simping for the milkman.
No way.
Wait, actually?
Oh.
Her eye is going the wrong way.
She's also not on the list.
What's wrong with my appearance?
Look carefully at the photos of my papers and compare them
with Well, with me.
No, I want you to get angry.
Get mad!
Okay.
You're boring.
Get out of here.
What'd you say?
Maybe I clicked the button before she finished talking.
Kind of spooked me, though.
Kind of scared me when I...
and she's like, look at the list again.
A lot of lewd fan art of him on Twitter!
That's crazy.
That's actually great.
Wait.
Is he on the sexy Tumblr man Tumblr website?
Good afternoon.
Good afternoon, Mr. Schmidt.
You have no stamp!
What's up with that?
Oh.
I am ruthless today.
Yes, but it's usually the other eye that is deviated.
Yeah.
No, I already said that.
As soon as she walked up, I recognized that.
I knew that already.
You guys are too slow.
It was her other eye that was that was offset why are you
guys why are you guys trying to correct me when i said that
i'm confused maybe i didn't word myself correctly
i'm just gonna brian rom welcome to membership thank you
they're correcting other people in jai oh okay
oh mint the other eye is offset No way!
What?
They're boo-seating.
Um, anyway.
Nana.
Chat backseating themselves.
It's okay.
I know.
This gets a little confusing.
Oh.
His nose is so...
wrong actually yeah what's wrong with your appearance i look
as handsome as ever you're so right
i want his confidence i want his confidence for real he just
has a cold he got stung by a bee oh no
Thank you!
You guys are putting in the work today.
Oh, hello, hello, hello, hello!
What is the meaning of life, universe, and everything else?
Forty-two!
Forty-two, forty-two!
Forty-two, forty-two.
That is correct.
What is the scientific name of the object?
Australian animal that drastically changes its appearance
when removed from its natural habitat.
Why did Google tell me the echidna?
So I say so I say so I Cyro Lutees Marsidus I'm I'm Cyro
Lutees Marsidus That's correct.
Good job guys.
Good job.
What is the name of the only sport that allows you to punch
your opponent in the face?
Because they capture a piece?
Rugby?
Chess boxing?
What?
That's a thing?
That's correct!
At least how many times do you have to fold a 0.01
millimeter thick sheet of paper to cover the distance
between...
The Shire and Mordor.
38?
What?
What does that even mean?
Wait, how many times do you have to fold a 0.01 millimeter
thick sheet of paper to cover the distance between the Shire
and Mordor?
What does that mean?
You have to fold it 38 times to...
Huh?
How many pages between mentions of the two, I guess?
Yeah, I don't really understand.
Every fold doubles the thickness.
Yeah, but...
Okay, okay, I think I get it.
It's just not possible, though.
That's correct!
Good job, Google.
The key is...
Hide...
Wait, what?
Oh, I screenshot it because I thought it was...
Wait.
What?
Uranus?
What does it mean, though?
What does the cipher mean?
I like how you guys are just looking this up and spoon
feeding it to me.
Thank you.
We're so smart today, guys.
That's correct.
Who would have thought?
How long is this quiz?
According to FSM Global Warming, Is a consequence of the
fact that since the 19th century, the number of blank
decrease.
Pirates.
Pirates?
Really?
That's correct.
You managed to answer all my questions correctly.
Congratulations, you have earned my badge.
Ah!
Thank you.
Uh...
Oh!
Goodbye!
MVP!
Except for when I- when it's for me!
Because I googled it and it said Echidna.
Why did it say Echidna?
Why?
That does not make any sense.
I thought there was maybe something about the Echidna that I
just didn't know.
I don't know.
Unless it was Chat GPT.
Who knows?
Bob Berger's looking ass.
Stop!
I think he's fine, but we're just gonna call please let you
know.
If I touch this thing, will I get diseased?
We'll figure, we'll find out after, if I touch this little
thing he gave me, that's a certified hot dog moment, can I
get a hot dog?
Thank you.
Bye-bye.
Nope, nothing happens if you click it.
Milkman!
Hello.
I forgot to show my entry request.
You're a milkman.
Thank you, Francis.
Oh my gosh, thank you for that.
Thank you, cat, called Meowie.
Tips are free.
No, they're not.
No, they are not.
Thank you, though.
Um, ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-bub-bub-bub-bub-bub.
Um, ba-bub-bub-bub-bub-bub.
I think he was fine, but who knows?
Oh my gosh, thank you for all the hot dogs!
Glizzy, overdrive, Thank you.
Oh my gosh, after this, I have to go blow my nose for real.
I had my door open today to kind of air out my maid cafe a
little bit, because, you know, since I haven't been living
here.
Oh, blah, blah, blah.
For a while it was a little stuffy and um Um But it let all
the pollen in too So I'm like extra Extra stuffy and coffee
today She's tommie They are my arms Like the arms of a
normal human She's so right You are so right.
That's fun.
We haven't seen that one before.
Oh, sniffer.
Very natural, very human.
Actually, those kind of looked like my hands, didn't they?
They kind of looked like...
They kind of looked like my hands.
When they're up, you know?
Good afternoon.
Do I have to let you think like one person in?
Oh my god, my nose is so itchy.
Maybe she was a ghost too.
Maybe.
Maybe is she like Maybe she was in the process Of becoming a
ghost You know she was dead And then she got brought back to
life Imagine giving Her a hug And then her neck arms Hug
your head too That's so romantic Good afternoon Where's your
entry request Thank you McLouis Rudd boys
I think he's good, but it's fine.
Romance.
Just like what I think of when I see Italy.
We're going to cause a time paradox.
Da-da-da-da.
Thank you.
Yes, romance, exactly.
Oh.
Yippee!
And we got five doppelgangers.
Oh, we only killed seven people in the process, too, but
that's okay.
Rank C!
And we got a new record, right?
Which is...
I can't believe that worked Wow Wow We actually managed to
unlock so many of these Obviously the 100 one is going to be
really difficult 40 playthroughs Unlock all achievements The
peach doppelganger and the doppelganger red-handed actually
if you are interested in playing this game too it is free um
there is like a download version that costs three dollars i
think so it's very inexpensive and then there's also a free
browser version dust go welcome to membu ship
um so uh yeah you can uh you can play it for free there's on
the in the online version just search up that's not my
neighbor you will be able to find it if you're interested in
playing it as well because it is pretty fun um look we've
already captured 31 doppelgangers that's not so bad what was
the how many was it like a hundred a hundred we're already
30 percent of the way there it's not so bad it's not so bad
Meg Fishnet Thank you Welcome, welcome, welcome Welcome And
send 13 We don't look at that part We don't look at this one
In fact, I'm gonna Actually, we only sent one neighbor We've
only killed one neighbor Yeah, no worries No worries at all
Well, that was good I'm glad that we could get the was last
two achievements then right very good stream hope you're
doing well thanks Robert thank you thank you this is so fun
Andrew welcome the membership thank you down thank you for
the 20 gifted thank you I have the I think my next day off I
will search for like artists and stuff for my for emotes and
everything um see who's open for for for what's the word um
commissions so yeah i will i will look into that my name is
jeff 10 out of 10 stream well thank you jeff glad you liked
it first time ever seeing this game it was fun i hope you
had a good rest tonight man thank you thank you Yeah, I, uh,
I was really, I saw this like a ton, um, on YouTube and
TikTok when I was in Japan, and so I was like, trying not to
watch so much of it, because I obviously wanted to play for
myself, and I didn't want to be so, uh, spoiled, I'm kind of
like, I don't want to call them anomaly, what kind of
doppelgangers you can get, right?
Thanks for the stream, Mint!
Unless you're not Mint, and you're a doppelganger, then
please give us Mint back!
Here, hold on.
Hold on.
Let's see.
Let's see if you can tell if I'm a doppelganger or not.
Hmm.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Let's see if you can tell if I'm a doppelganger or not.
Okay.
I'm going to come in.
You're going to tell me if I'm a doppelganger.
Hmm.
Hello!
Am I normal?
Sauce?
Where?
Why?
Why sauce?
Actually, here, let's let's actually move over to here.
I'm gonna exit out of the game so we don't get this creepy
music anymore.
Um...
Put on some music.
Some music.
There we go.
Sus double-maided?
Then you send me...
Then you call the police on me and I get flushed down the
toilet.
Okay, let me try one other one.
Oh.
Let me try another one.
Let's see.
I.
Um.
Uh.
That one was too easy.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, this one, this one.
You'll never get it.
You'll never know.
Okay, ready?
Huh?
Unchanged.
This is normal.
That's what I'm saying.
All right?
You don't know.
Okay, I'm going to give you another one.
but you have to tell me you have to figure it out this one
is normal or wait okay no this one okay figure out which one
is normal this one or
this one which one
yes I'm a very dignified gentleman It's getting my eyes.
It's itchy.
Why is it so wiggly?
There we go.
What do I make it bigger?
Like this.
This is peak.
This is what every man should strive to be.
This is peak masculinity.
Peak normal.
Robotnik.
Man!
Oh, I need a eye patch.
Oh, no, a monocle.
There's so many things here that are fun to use.
Like, let's see what else we got in here.
Um...
What?
There's boba in here too.
Hold on, I want to try it.
Whoa!
How does this work?
Yummy!
Wait.
It can hold it in my hands.
Right?
Whoa!
Look at me, I got my bubble tea.
Wow, it's so fancy.
Oh my gosh.
Delicious.
We have the technology.
Wow, this is so cool.
What does it say?
Boba, tea, coffee?
Oh, like, BTS, VTube Studio.
Oh my gosh, that's so cute.
V2 Studio is great, right?
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
Yippee!
It's kind of drippy though.
It's getting my sleeves wet.
Can we have a sippy too?
Drink up.
Here, I'll put it in the sand.
Okay.
I'm feeding you.
suckle suckle from the straw see if you can see if you can
catch it only the strongest will survive come on come
on if you can't get it you won't live to see another day
I am trying what else is there let's see
There's also these.
Well, these look good on me, though, I wonder.
Okay, I'm going to try.
Wait.
I'm going to disappear.
Wait, I'm confused, actually.
Wait, hold on.
Why is it just...
I'm confused.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, you guys ready?
You guys ready?
This
one's kind of, well, maybe it was just the angle.
What do you think?
So it would have been perfect for Easter.
Too bad.
Too bad we announced everything the day after.
Bunny.
Bunny, bunny.
You probably won't have to worry about this, but it could be
an idea of how placeholder emotes while looking for someone
to commission.
But I think you'll have plenty of members for months not
worry about it.
Oh, that's a good idea.
idea that's a good point though because yeah oh you're right
i might lose them i might lose them it's a lot of fun thank
you man thank you thank you for the don't know thank you i
like how when i blink they move that's so fancy the
technology the technology is real and they also like flop
back and forth
Yay!
Too cute.
So cute.
Yeah, I'll probably find a couple artists that can do some
stuff so that I'm not stressing one artist out with 37.
37 slots.
However many it was.
It was 37, wasn't it?
Or did I just see that in chat and believed it?
37 copies of Bustin.
Yes.
Dr. Cornelius.
Thank you for the bamboo ship.
God hand.
Ah, God hand.
37.
You counted them yourself.
Delete.
Control.
Welcome to the bamboo ship.
Thank you.
38.
37 colors of busting oh my gosh we just make it a full
spectrum that'll be crazy it's like a full rainbow spectrum
like every individual color you can think of 37 stab wounds
yeah well guys this was fun um thank you for hanging out
with me today uh with this thank you for understanding um
when i was just like i don't know no i'm not part of me for
for tomodachi life i was like obviously i can put in like
some uh some what's what's the word uh like fictional
characters we can put in like video game characters anime
characters whoever we want um but for or like even like
celebrities or it's like you know just be goofy but um for
some of the people that i was just like oh like you know um
for other people that i might know personally if i wanted to
put them in i wanted to um thank you i wanted to make sure i
ask for like you know permission you know like i want to be
like i don't want to just put them in the game and they uh
you know so i wanted i was just like oh you know i thought
about it like kind of like really only today so i was like
oh shoot um not that i have like so many people that I would
include, but just in case anybody that I know that I might
include, yeah, I just want to make sure that they're okay
with it.
Before I add them in.
Like Matara?
No, I'm never asking if she's comfortable.
I want her to be as uncomfortable as possible all the time.
Okay, tomorrow will probably be a bit of a longer stream
because it's Metal Gear!
Yippee!
Mint the rabbit hole animation.
Hmm?
Rabbit hole?
Yeah, I'll be playing Twin Snakes tomorrow for the first
time ever.
So I'm nervous.
If I'm bad, I'm sorry.
I haven't played Metal Gear yet.
in quite some time so but uh we will have fun regardless oh
the meco envy
yeah yeah yeah yeah i know it i know i know it yes yes yes i
forgot i forgot what it was called big ham welcome to
membership thank you um but yeah so metal gear tomorrow be
hype hype hype hype so excited to play it twin sticks
finally and um yeah uh probably will be a bit of a longer
stream so that i can get through a good amount of it and i
will make sure i well hopefully i will get enough sleep
tonight hopefully um yeah
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I will see you guys tomorrow.
And yeah.
Bye-bye.
Oh, we can do Bustin.
Actually, it's so funny.
Yesterday, I watched a trailer of an anime.
And I got bonked.
Like, so the stream got demonetized.
The stream got demonetized.
Because they were like, um, you showed the trailer and
you...
Also watched it.
So I have to be careful about that kind of stuff, I suppose.
Yeah.
It's okay, though.
I'm not, like, gonna cry about it.
But I want to make sure that things aren't so loud so that
they don't get caught so easily, you know?
Yeah, the Maid Wars one.
Even though I was just like...
look over top of it it recognized the video which is so
crazy right are there something strange sleeping in your bed
let me tell you something done is there something weird
sleeping in your bed oh let me tell you something busting
makes me feel good
you paused it a bunch uh too many times and they still
caught it i know right i was i was really surprised
youtube's uh it makes me worried about about live streams
and stuff like that now like watching the animals and stuff
at the aquarium
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, an invisible man sleeping in
your bed.
Oh, garlum, I'll thank you!
No, no, really, it's okay.
Oh my gosh, that's a picture going perfectly with the song.
Feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good.
But stand, but stand, but stand, but stand, but stand.
Bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin,
bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin,
bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, freaky ghost man,
baby.
Ow, ow.
bed
let me tell you something sleeping makes me feel good I'm
afraid of no sleep I'm afraid of no bed an invisible bed
freaky ghost bed yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Bustin, bustin makes me feel good, feel good, feel good,
feel good, feel good, feel good Yeah, yeah, yeah Bustin,
bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin makes
me feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good,
feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel
good, yeah, yeah, yeah
Say feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good,
feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel
good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good,
feel good, feel good, thank you guys, thank you, oh, bye
bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, see you tomorrow, bye, bye, bye,
bye, bye, bye, see you tomorrow, bye, bye, bye,